a discovery as beautiful as it is
hopeful
this huge reef filled with rose-shaped
corals was found by scientists off the
coast of tahiti
unusually it's in pristine condition
unharmed by pollution or people
well it's exciting because it's uh it's
a healthy reef and
you know
if you look at the stories it's it's
quite
quite going the opposite we have lost
about half of our coral reefs in the
last 70 years
and uh it's really the stuff that makes
you dream and it makes you really
understand the beauty and the treasure
of the uh of a marine environment in the
ocean
the reef was discovered by a team of
unesco scientists using state-of-the-art
diving equipment that allowed them to
stay deeper
after 200 hours of diving they measured
the reef at three kilometers long and
stretching down to 70 meters below sea
level that makes it one of the world's
largest at this depth and raises the
prospect of more reefs waiting to be
found
more dives are planned in the coming
months to study the reef and the marine
life that has made it their home
but its discovery shows how little we
still know about our underwater world
katie barnfield sky news